J'ai parlé sans le nadir de cette
difficulté que j'ai eue avec la maladie de Parkinson,
dit-elle, les premiers stades peuvent être appartement
oui mon cerveau manque de quelque chose de
dopamine et régule les or comme un
bouton pas du tout dans la meilleure
partie est qu'il y a des médicaments ça remplace
ça  la dopamine ce n'est pas un remède, mais vous
pouvez ralentir les progrès, c'est encourageant,
mais je joue beaucoup plus longtemps, ce n'est
pas dans les cartes pour moi et si les
médicaments fonctionnent, je dois être sincère à propos de cet
accord avec lui, nommez-le, le médecin dit que cela
pourrait  me donner une saison pourrait être aussi mais
j'ai pris ma décision alors il vaut mieux que le
quatuor planifie à l'avance pense à ce qui
vient ensuite je pense que nina leigh devrait
me remplacer elle est merveilleuse violoncelliste nous
ne l'aimons pas c'est celle que tout le monde
accepte  Daniel Nina et elle
joue toujours avec Gideon non je ne suis pas d'
accord avec nous nous ne devrions pas en discuter
maintenant ce n'est pas le moment je suis d'accord sur
une chose de plus si ce médicament fonctionne et
je suis capable de jouer assez bien d'ici là je
j'aimerais  le premier concert de la saison sera mon
adieu